[Music]
there can only be one not if Hollywood
has its way this week's keynotech news
is dominated by sequels Barbie 2 is
being discussed a Spider-Man 4 around
Toby Maguire seems to be on the horizon
and the theatrical release of Doom 2 is
at serious risk there is also new info
on saw 10 and the John Wick series the
Continental curious here are the details
a shock for all Dune fans due to the
currently ongoing actor strike in
Hollywood the release of Dune 2 might be
delayed considerably the prospects for a
return to Iraqis in the near future are
getting worse and worse at present both
writers and actors in the United States
are on strike for better working
conditions this not only brings planned
and ongoing Productions to a standstill
however even movies that are already
finished can no longer be publicly
promoted by the Stars which is a
disaster for the Distributors who
naturally want to attract as much
attention as possible to their
theatrical releases that's why some of
them are now pulling the ripcord and
postponing their finished films among
them Challengers starring Zendaya which
is now scheduled for release at the end
of April 2024 instead of this September
now one of the most highly anticipated
movies of the year can also fall victim
to the postponement plans namely Dune
part 2 by Dennis villenev the science
fiction epic Dune starring Timothy
chalamet wowed many viewers and critics
in 2021 and also swap the board at the
Academy Awards the sequel was already
considered the Undisputed highlight of
the 2023 movie year yet according to
deadline the excitement is now being
dampened distributor Warner Brothers is
seriously contemplating pushing Doom 2
back to next year with march to June
2024 being the first period of
discussion there is still some hope that
the state will be averted should actors
and producers be able to agree on an end
to the strike by the Labor Day weekend
of September 3rd to the 5th the current
theatrical release of Doom 2 on November
3rd 2023 would remain unchanged
Barbie has just hit theaters and there's
already talk of Barbie too director
Greta Gerwig and leading actress Margot
Robbie have now commented on a possible
sequel to The Summer hit the film about
the iconic plastic doll already managed
to bring in over 155 million dollars on
its opening weekend in the United States
a resounding success never before in the
history of Hollywood as a female
directed movie been able to bring in so
much money in the first few days Barbie
thus beats the former record holder
Wonder Woman by Patty Jenkins which
brought in 105 million dollars
accordingly it's not surprising that
people are already calling for a sequel
lead actress Margot Robbie expressed
herself rather reserved in an interview
with time about a potential Barbie
follow-up it could go in a million
different directions but you'd be
falling for a trap if you tried to set
up a first movie while also planning for
sequels director Greta Gerwig on the
other hand is not entirely averse to the
idea as she revealed in an interview on
the total film podcast she is currently
focusing on the next few days for now
says anything is possible the first part
was a wonderful experience in which she
was able to fully live up to her dreams
she has already spoken positively in the
past about the thought that the movie
could become a franchise there seems to
be no lack of general interest and
creative ideas and distributor Warner
Brothers would certainly not object to
following up the box office success of
Barbie however Reddit Gerwig is expected
to be busy with her next job for the
time being a reinterpretation of The
Chronicles of Narnia for Netflix
meanwhile Barbie is probably just the
beginning of a cinema initiative by
rights holder Mattel as variety reports
a true Mattel Cinematic Universe is
planned currently a total of 14 of the
company's brands are being brought in
for this including adaptations of the
purple dinosaur Barney the classic Polly
Pocket the racing Toys Hot Wheels and
Thomas and Friends Mattel's He-Man movie
was only recently canceled by Netflix in
the midst of production due to excessive
costs and is now looking for new backers
the success of Barbie is now surely
opening up some new opportunities for
the manufacturer it remains to be seen
whether the next movies will be able to
build on this
it would be a sensation Spider-Man fans
May yet be able to enjoy a fourth
Spider-Man movie with Toby Maguire new
rumors are fueling hopes of a reunion
with the iconic neighborhood spider
director Sam raimi's Spider-Man trilogy
starring Toby Maguire is considered a
cult favorite and a glorious start to a
new era of comic book adaptations after
Spider-Man 3 another film was originally
supposed to be released to conclude The
Saga of Peter Parker unfortunately due
to differences between Sony and Sam
Raimi this never came to be since then
fans have been eagerly awaiting the
chance to enjoy a sequel once again this
possibility now seems more tangible than
ever actor Thomas Hayden Church best
known for the Sandman from part 3 spoke
in an exclusive interview with
comicbook.com about hearing certain
rumors namely about Sam Raimi making
another movie with Toby Maguire should
this film come to fruition Church could
also Imagine a comeback in his role as
Sandman after the surprising appearance
of Tobey Maguire in the last Spider-Man
Adventure no way home there were plenty
of rumors and hopes for a last solo
Adventure as well as for another The
Amazing Spider-Man movie with Andrew
Garfield Sam Raimi directed Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse abandoness
last year and expressed his interest
several times and finally releasing his
last Spider-Man movie we will see
whether the rumors prove to be true for
many fans however this would certainly
be the Fulfillment of a dream
fans of brutal horror listen up the
successful saw saga continues with its
10th installment and now presents us
with a new poster which gives us an idea
of the Cinematic horror that will unfold
this September one thing is clear it's
getting bloody again two years ago
spiral from the book of Saw starring
Chris Rock was supposed to be a new take
on the franchise but it was only
partially successful now the 10th part
of the popular spider series is in the
pipeline and returns to its former
strengths Tobin Bell is back once again
as jigsaw saw 10 is to be set between
saw 1 and Saw 2 and lets him live out
his penchant for nasty instruments of
torture again the freshly released
poster takes a ghoulish approach to the
letter X and once again promises wacky
constructions around the human body the
basic plot of the new film is already
known after the events of saw one John
Kramer who suffers from cancer travels
to Mexico where he hopes that a special
treatment will help cure his condition
however this treatment turns out to be a
scam by unscrupulous swindlers who want
to to exploit the emergency situation of
helpless people for their own benefit in
response Kramer decides to take bloody
revenge in addition to Togan Bell in his
well-known role as Kramer AKA jigsaw the
cast is joined by Stephen brand who may
be familiar to some from his roles and
Vikings Valhalla or the Sandman series
the movie was directed by Kevin Bruder
who already directed Saw 6 and saw 7 and
was also in charge of editing Parts one
to five as well as saw eight in other
words he's a true connoisseur of the
franchise in the United States the movie
opens in theaters on September 29 2023
so it shouldn't take too much longer
until we can show you the first saw 10
trailer
finally the release date for the
Continental from the world of John Wick
has been announced that's not all
however further images of the series
have also been revealed further raising
the fans excitement in the course of the
San Diego Comic-Con 2023 the release
date of the much anticipated John Wick
series was revealed the Continental is
scheduled to premiere on September 22nd
2023 on peacock in the United States due
to the currently ongoing writers and
actor strike the on-site panel was sadly
rather sparsely attended nevertheless
director and producer Albert Hughes and
others presented exclusive shots to the
fans gathered at the event after the
first teaser trailer some time ago the
new images of the cast make us eager for
more for example we see the young
Winston played by Colin Waddell standing
in an elevator presumably in the
eponymous hotel we likewise get a first
impression of Mel Gibson who will play a
New York gangster boss and the current
manager of the Continental named cormack
his intimidating appearance suggests
that he is unlikely to and over the
Continental to Winston unopposed
Michelle Prada will embody a female
police officer from the NYPD she 2 seems
to be in the Continental this could
indicate that much of the action will
take place inside of the hotel also we
get to see a first look at ayomide
atagun as a young version of Sharon a
faithful sidekick to Cormac the brother
and sister Duo blew in Miles played by
Jessica Elaine and Hubert Point du jour
will also be involved and will create
some Buzz we can hardly wait to delve
back into the world of John Wick the
series acts as a prequel and will tell
us the Gory story of young Winston and
his rise to become the manager of the
Continental which in the later John Wick
movies is the ultimate Haven for Hitmen
the release of the Continental on
September 22nd is definitely highlighted
in our calendars
that's it for the most important news of
the week is there a topic that didn't
make it into the video that's important
to you tell us and the others about it
in the comments and if you still need
tips on what to watch now have a look at
our Originals we've got new previews on
Snow White Star Wars the Acolyte and a
quiet place day one just visit our
Channel overview and scroll through all
the amazing content that we provide you
each week thanks for watching and we'll
see you next week
[Music]
foreign